Is Overwhelming Stampede a good card in
Commander? I mean, on a basic level, the
answer is yes. It's a popular card that
can turn a moderately beefy board into
one or more dead players in short order.
But is it always good? Obviously not. If
I don't have a substantial board, I'd
much prefer this to be a creature I can
play or a removal spell to set back an
opponent. Likewise, let's say I have a
massive board. Maybe I just had a
bonkers turn. Is the card good then?
Well, no, it's not. I don't need this
card to win in this case, and it would
be better if it was a piece of
protection or removal to make 100% sure
I make it back to my turn with this
board, or maybe even a haste enabler to
let me swing on my bonkers's turn.
Overwhelming stampede is good when I
have a board that is large but not quite
large enough to win, bridging that gap
that exists there. To decide whether
it's a good card for your deck, you need
to ask yourself, how often is this the
situation I'm in? And how often will the
situation be one of these other two?